twice a month they go to war at least
that's what it looks like at first
glance these paramilitaries say they
want to protect Slovakia as though the
country wasn't part of a Europe at peace
but instead surrounded by enemies of
parents if a future enemy sees what's
going on here in Slovakia if he sees a
country that is prepared to defend
itself and it's democratic values then
that enemy will think twice about
attacking he'll think again before
trying to take away our rights Peter
Schreyer check is the so-called
Commandant of the Slovak paramilitary
organization slavonski brod see the 20
year old and his troops say they're
ready to fend off what they view as
foreign threats to Slovakia that
includes refugees security risk and most
importantly a lot of them are here
illegally a lot of them even at the
height of the crisis last year when
thousands of migrants arrived in Europe
every day only a couple of hundred ended
up in cap cheek oval a village on the
border with Hungary even that number
caused an uproar in Slovakia now there
are just a few migrants left here the
residents have grown used to them they
are doing anything wrong they're here
because of the war back home I don't
feel threatened many say they're more
frightened of the uniformed men in the
forests nearby those who externa bronzy
are extremists there are the ones that
need to be controlled
members of the slavonski brod seat
paramilitary are known to hold extremist
right-wing views the group claims it
only exists to protect democracy but
comments on internet forums reveal the
opposite conditioning tactics and to
hand combat slavonski brod sea drills
are demanding the largest paramilitary
organisation in slovakia doesn't protect
democracy it poses a threat to it says
journalist me Hal aren nom nom is
newsroom I'm very worried because we
know that a significant part of the
Slovakian army and police force are
members of this group think the bucum it
isn't a coincidence that the
paramilitary is trained by professional
soldiers of the Slovakian army swastika
Ramadi
bTW and some police have also fought on
the side of neo-nazis in right-wing
brawls the kalashnikovs that the members
of the paramilitary carry are supposedly
collectors firearms that have been
disabled but it's relatively easy to
make them work again the Charlie Hebdo
attacks in Paris last year were carried
out with Slovakian collector's weapons
at the interior ministry in the capital
Bratislava authorities played down the
possible dangers individual extremists
are under surveillance but not the
paramilitary groups as a whole in legal
terms these groups don't exist if they
break the law then of course they'll be
punished
we can't ban groups like this because as
I say legally they don't exist in the
neighboring Czech Republic groups like
this Levinsky but uncie have long been
banned but in Slovakia a right-wing
party is now represented in Parliament
mayor Hobart on borns that xenophobic
paramilitaries could take advantage of
the country's new political climate
assumption to video people I think they
know this is their big chance they're
fighting to become accepted by the
public so their future depends on us on
what we do with this country and this
continent of mussel stock need to trust
if we don't resist their influence will
grow octopus genius Laden image in
private the Commandant of the slavonski
brod C plays down his weekend activities
but the first semester archeology
student knows exactly what he's doing at
16 he traveled to Russia for military
training and every month more and more
paramilitary groups are accepting his
leadership we have a reputation for
being fascist or extremist it's really
unfortunate that's why many of us have
been fired or have problems finding jobs
that happens to us all the time
the young commandant might have even
bigger ambitions
before long he could decide to take his
ideals out of the woods and onto the
political stage